[Musique]
une visite dans le cadre du projet de
loi climat et résilience oran verger
rapporteur du volet consommation et
michel edouard leclerc se sont rendus
dans une grande surface du groupe ce
lundi le plan france relance concerne
aussi le patrimoine le préfet de la
région ile de france marc guillaume
s'est rendu au moulin de saint cyr
l'école et à l'école nationale
supérieure d'architecturé de versailles
deux projets à 9 et 30 millions d'euros
à saint germain en laye le quartier de
l'hôpital va se voir transformer
jusqu'en 2026 le clos saint louis est un
projet d'écoquartier 5000 m² de
commerces et 450 logements sont
notamment prévus après un tournage de
week-end dernier la révélation du clip
le rappeur unis montante carte 1 a écrit
un morceau sur tracts une réponse à
l'emballement médiatique après les
propos du professeur de philosophie
dédié le maire les gendarmes aux côtés
de la population rurale du département
dans plusieurs communes les militaires
investissent des bureaux pour recevoir
les habitants et c'est un effet
inattendu de la crise de lakovic 19 plus
de vingt mille entreprises ont été
créées dans le département des yvelines
en 2020
[Musique]